foreign
shoes ankle boots they are around one
year old my customer brought these boots
and she said that her dog bit and chewed
her boots the weather strip on the heel
block is chewed the heel plate is broken
and came off from the hill
now I'm removing the weather straight on
the hill block because it was damaged so
it needs to be replaced
I'm using a scrapper to remove the
leather strip
I have to be careful about scratching
the hill
I'm sending the hill to remove lazadoo
and this makes the surface even and
level for later steps
foreign sandpaper
I have to be careful about standing
smoothly and lightly
I'm using a cotton pads to apply thinner
onto the heel and it removes glue like I
do
[Music]
foreign
strip
I made a pattern using the heel block
and using it to cut out the new leather
strip
[Music]
I'm using a glue brush to apply leather
glue to post here block and leather
stream
[Music]
this helps the piece of adhere better
and last longer
[Music]
[Music]
I'm replacing the broken plastic heel
plate with new rubber heel plate
now I'm tracing the old plastic heel
plate with a pencil I'm cutting out the
new rubber plate with a rubber cutting
machine
I'm using a cutting knife to cut the
excess material of the rudder strip off
I'm applying lower glue to the hill when
putting on the replacement the lower hip
plate
I'm applying the glue to both the heel
and the replacement piece because this
helps the piece of the heater better and
last longer
I'm using a hammer to press the new
rubber heel plate onto the shoe I'm
replacing the broken plastic heel plate
with a lower one because the lower heel
plate is more durable and less slippery
I'm using a sanding motion to smooth the
edge of lower heel plate
I'm using a sponge to apply acrylic
paint to the edge of the rubber heel
plate for color match
foreign
so I'm very glad that she is able to
wear them again